[Music]
have you guys heard of Orbeez Orbeez
like where you get your roast beef
sandwiches that's that bull or bees kids
all the kids tubers that use them dr.
pols with Orbeez yeah and it looks very
colorful little boy they're not plastic
but little tiny little beads that grow
in water and then like a lot of kids
play with it the kids toy turns into a
sea monkey no not even close you don't
see you don't don't see monkeys I always
ask that question no it's that it's that
dry thing and it's like if you soak it
in water it turns into like a beach
bunch so it was originally invented to
maintain soil like to keep soil wet and
like planting oh the Hat thing those
white dot be nice no not that one how do
you know what he's talking about exactly
it looks like styrofoam thank you garden
then you know these days I'm a
horticulturalist horticulturalist
horticulture you don't know what that is
no what is it
whales live in my dream right now I'll
never you know you know Kristin has a
[ __ ] farm with a random view what is
horticulture so our friend Tony Tran is
a horticultural transplant [ __ ] everyone
knows we is I thought nobody knew and I
hope it's new and [ __ ] no keeps for
eating cold drink as usual there's seven
brains in the room we have no idea
what's going on I'm telling you he made
it up horticulture horticulture exists
you don't realize don't [ __ ] Steve I
hate you I'm dead serious excellent
horticulture it that's a real thing
horrible it's not towards a person who
does [ __ ] with I don't know plants it
it's horrid culture I don't nice is it a
harlot Cory I have to look tip you don't
have to do
tell us about the sandwiches please we
can't do the art practice of garden
cultivation and management's horeb am i
pronouncing these a horticultural it's
the Horde a horticultural yes it is
there's a tea horticulturalist
holy [ __ ] listen listen listen hor TI ya
by use a [ __ ] - geez still wonder
becomes the de grammar nazi' can we talk
about the five for $5 as our bees and
their crazy friend watch an ad D our
thanks so this guy this french guy named
cyril
he went viral because he ended up doing
something very stupid
oh god this is what he looks like he's a
youtuber guy he does a lot of pranks
usually on his channel he looks French
yes oh yeah very French he looks like
you like espresso yes so this this one
person they tweeted like parts of his
misfortune and that tweet went viral so
sweet says this french guy filled his
tub with Orbeez and had no idea how to
get rid of them so he just pulled the
plug which resulted in Orbeez
overflowing both in his toilet and
things he pranked himself poor buddy but
it gets so much better yes okay so I'm
gonna be playing a video clip of
compilation of all these other video
clips cuz he kept like giving updates on
what's happening in the situation so
it's gonna start with help when he first
started filling in the tub so it's a
little out of order at how she tweeted
it how cute oh those are cool
Wow pretty cool it's coming out
everywhere Wow and then you start over
with them I freaked out oh my god it's
destroying a city I thought it was a
Martin's bridge oh my god that's actual
French [ __ ] no more bees can be murdered
a pen that's [ __ ] straight French
touching it what what's with all [ __ ]
our bees everywhere
they're all bees dad fall straight [ __ ]
two cities you should put it up in rice
and then that would have bored more rice
in there he keeps [ __ ] it up harder
and harder to filled his bathroom with
rice ya know what happens they are
biodegradable okay so it doesn't harm
the environment it very explicitly says
like do not put in a drain like don't
let it drain out because because of the
fact that it expands with water it will
talk about everything
whoa how big did he get huge but I saw
some that were like this big it's just
boba balls it reminds me of boba like
tapioca you're so agent you are pretty
Asian I think about gummy bears when I
see them and I'm disappointed that they
cannot be eaten at the epoch yeah
likewise it looks like jello I want to
fill a bathtub like that but what's warm
water it'll be really nice true oh yeah
so this guy's gone viral and everyone's
like what a [ __ ] idiot so then he
ends are responding to that that uh
initial tweet I wonder what the if the
neighbors had that [ __ ] cuz if it's all
over the city I'd be kind of excited a
little bit
Woodcock on Orbeez you know I just came
out of your toilet cuz your neighbor put
it in his okay
no I wouldn't enter what the [ __ ]
going on but I've like they're kind of
cute yeah kind of cute first be like
whoa oh yeah if it's just Orbeez the
[ __ ] Orbeez fairy bless my toil
because imagine if you're taking a [ __ ]
in or bee starts [ __ ] floating up in
your [ __ ]
that's but it's better than having [ __ ]
flow that look yeah or the Orbeez lifts
up your [ __ ] there was a song cool
we are hands at respond like hello it's
me the idiot oh what a good something
humor but yeah he [ __ ] up yeah and so
now he's saying that he's been
subpoenaed city like the Town Hall poor
dude thanks to you we have a lot of
evidence yeah also filmed everything so
we have that as well because initially
he was trying to hide his identity like
there were neighborhoods coming he's
like now when they see him like hey oh
really yeah so I'm saying that now he
has to face fines I don't know how much
but because he's destroying city
property the video will pay for it I
appreciated this story though it was
like she [ __ ] up I mean the directions
were probably in English why was he
supposed to go maybe he's lucky he
didn't get worse you didn't [ __ ] feed
his dog war because it starts coming out
of his mouth and [ __ ] some people are
pretty stupid out there but yeah so I
don't know man this [ __ ] was so
hilarious especially seeing like how it
was tweeted out cuz it was in sections
and seen like the progression of the
story because it ended up beginning with
him seeing the the whole like toilet
overflow with in the sink and everything
and then later on should post the vacuum
cleaner Breaking and it's just it was
[ __ ] funny Wow but yeah everyone's
like responding with like I don't speak
French at all but you're getting a
follow for that one all I can't in
French people freaked out it's kind of
fun yeah it's elegant freaking out
toilet there like back in the day when
they were invaded like another country
and hear how they sound yeah yeah yeah
the sound of a white flag whipping in
the air because they don't fight yeah
they don't really fight they wouldn't
they invaded Napoleon yeah yeah yeah
what happened Napoleon they've got soft
bomb and they helped us in the early the
Revolutionary War yeah very true very
true I don't know if they helped much
though you know what you're dealing life
is French [ __ ] Irish in this video
it's very fun and I'm Irish yeah
we have a piece you know like this yeah
yeah we have while we fight like this
and marry they go no no no you don't
know what your neck is the keys please
because they like potatoes right is that
I know we like we like to do this okay
and then the French are like oh we're
gonna cut them up and call them fries
exactly that does one of the og things
that pisses off the money these
[ __ ] Americans piss us off -
with that Chris cut fries [ __ ] what
about the curly fries that what about
the curly fries who did that Jack the
Jack the [ __ ] Japanese did it man did
they make the curly [ __ ] yeah that's
what that's what the jacket easeness
Jack Andy started the cabbage but thanks
thanks to people like my grandpa who was
killing the Japanese yeah curly fries
are delicious you fought for our rights
why are you like a different kind of
potato it looks like this season yeah
the point where I think breaded yeah
like jack-in-the-box and Arby's curly
fries bobbin very poppin I like the job
I think the jack-in-the-box curly fries
are epic I agree do you like those more
you like the Carl's jr. Chris cut fries
more calls jr. Chris go fries Chris cut
fries I think are a [ __ ] joke why Oh
what yeah I do you only call crunchy and
crispy there I don't like the pattern I
like the way you smell I wish they would
go out of my [ __ ] country my god the
awesome thing about this country is that
we have so many different options for
fries I just wish we just kept it simple
I don't know I don't like all these new
fries coming in the whole potato it
makes me feel insecure about my fried
choices that fry privilege right there
Hey look you keep them straight and you
keep them golden yeah keep them straight
and unseasoned that's all I need you
want some straight unseasoned plain
that's right oh yeah they're so salty
that I'm a little mushy a little tiny
little bit of motion crispy but I think
we can see we all agree the master fry
race is established
[Music]
[Music]